breathe in her left breathing relax all
right I don't know why so today we're
gonna be getting tattoos in places that
are considered a little more painful
than others we did a little research and
it turns out that if it's closer to the
bone it tends to be more painful so this
is Mike he's gonna be tattooing me today
all right yeah boom I am nervous mike
says that pain is subjective and
sometimes what people think is gonna be
the most painful turns out to not be
painful at all my personal experience
right on top of bone is way easier there
yeah yeah
Ella's getting hers on her finger I'm
gonna get mine behind my ear and
Fernando's gonna get his on his ankle
pain is very subjective so we'll see if
this actually lives up to this test
[Music]
but that as I thought I know my face
says otherwise
I thought my hitch
in the beginning I would say - and then
it went to like four and then five and
then like at the very end that felt like
nine it was like it wasn't necessarily
on the bone it was like the aerocart
breathe and relax breathing relax
we
[Laughter]
Sara definitely like a lot of spots were
like oh yeah that [ __ ] hurts especially
like my face was shaking because I
couldn't tense up I knew he wasn't in
the back of my ear but it felt like the
tattoo was happening they're
transferring yeah I mean I've been
tattooed on my arm and I can feel it in
the tip of my nose yeah it's like not a
pain it was it was an experience
[Music]
[Music]
what are we like 50% they're like 30 no
run
[Music]
most of it was like a six there was a
few parts in the middle that felt like a
nine or ten but I think overall I took
this much better than my other tech unit
you know for me it was it's not about
the tattoo it's like about the
experience like just proving to myself
that I can take on challenges I'm afraid
of needles I think burying blood tests I
didn't want to tell him the lower he got
the more painful it became and I feel
like that might be because I got closer
to the bone came out a better person
when I got close to my Achilles that
hurt a lot and you know over the bone
right like the whole [ __ ] thing I
heard a lot but it was not as bad as I
thought it would be Mike was right the
most painful places to get a tattoo can
be subjective and it changes from person
to person so get tatted up
[Music]
[Music]